oh god this is gonna get so weird so we
are doing the sexy challenge taking
store-bought not so sexy customs and
making them sexy is there any costume
that you can't make sexy Donald Trump
other than that though I think most
everything can be made sexy literally
anything is fair game I believe that any
costume can you make sixties what level
of sexiness this is or what finish it
really covers it depends oh my gosh oh
god a costume I got is a wizard sorcerer
I've been given the beekeepers costume
everything that is required to be a
clown a rock and rooster funky chicken
laughs I think this is gonna be pretty
easy there's like a lot of fabric I get
to choose what part of it six because
it's kind of like a blank canvas the
sexy clown is nightmare fuel and this is
gonna be [ __ ] I want it to be like a
like a goth dominatrix chicken this is
real fashion so I think you got to lose
the fingers to the gloves so it's like a
fingerless sexy clown glove I'm gonna
cut me a little split keeping it sexy
taking off the sleeves the sleeves have
got to go any sexy outfit doesn't have
sleeves you know that we all know that
what if I like didn't wear shirt
underneath and like just cut out the
nipples I'm just gonna like Regina
George this to start with I don't know
if sexy is the right word but it's
really swinging for it Oh proving hard
now you know make some like mysterious
peep holes in a 2d mesh like assless
chaps Oh what the hell we are gonna do
with this wig and I think you got a go
repeat clown mohawk jeez Louise I mean
this is pretty hot another thing I can't
stress enough don't do this at
home also like maths are kind of sexy
and general yeah I mean that's good
pretty that's pretty good I think that
if you put your mind to it you can make
any costume sexy I think like if I was
to do again I would tie these guys on
like I tied the beat in my head maybe
they can come off during the party and
that's part of it it's kind of like I'm
being attacked by a vase and what then
succeed for the bees I look like a
psycho big fan of the nipple gaps I
don't but I kind of do I was doubting
myself before and I'm pretty confident I
think we all do a really good job if you
can't make this cross-section of costume
sexy then I think the sky's the limit
you want to be sexy be funny silly be
like stylish you would you want do you I
know it you know it I'm a very sexy
verifying element solution we woke up
halfway to this and be like someone
robbed the customer Dorothy